i will use pro and con list but really
what i think is more helpful is a risk
benefit so you're writing down sort of
the best
case scenarios and the worst case
scenarios for different options you
could use that for choosing to invest in
a given company or not you could use
that for a million different things and
if the downside is capped if you can cap
the downside and there is
asymmetrical upside meaning you might
make 2x 10x 100x 1000x
then you know at least your maximum
losses okay so risk benefit i find more
helpful than pro con which can just be a
laundry list of different things to
compare and contrast i don't find that
terribly actionable now layered on top
of all of this
is
what is sometimes called a whole body
yes and i was exposed to this by diana
chapman and jim detmer of the
conscious leadership group i think i'm
getting the name of the company correct
and this is what it looks like it's very
simple you're considering a decision
and you scan
head
heart chest
gut there are other ways to do this you
could go to your loins too but let's
just say you're going with head
chest area heart and gut
you look for a yes signal a go signal in
all three areas
that is the only situation in which you
should say yes now what i find
a little challenging is identifying what
a yes feels like so what i do instead is
i look for no signals
what that means is if i feel any
contraction or grinding of the gears in
my head it's a no if i feel any
contraction in my chest
or my chest area it's a no i feel
anything in my gut it's a no all right
these are disconfirming
and where this is helpful is you can do
the risk benefit analysis you can do all
these types of analyses
and come to the conclusion that you
should do something something is a good
idea but if it feels off
i have learned to say no
especially as it relates to people if
you just get some spider sense intuition
this is the good case the useful case
that you shouldn't do something or
something feels off say no
so intuition i find most helpful when it
is pointing a different direction from
your analysis okay so you believe you
should do something
and your intuition says no but you
really want to do it i would err on the
side of listening to what we'll call
intuition in this case
if the math doesn't make sense this
doesn't make sense but perhaps you
should do it now this financially only
makes sense i think if you have a lot of
money and you can cap your losses and
you have some investing experience
sometimes things can work out when you
just get a really good feeling about
someone you can also piss away a lot of
money so caveat emptor so big life
decisions
that's also
there are some people who prefer to make
them with lists and pros and cons and
try to be rational about them and there
are other people who cannot escape the
sense that it's a gut and they just have
to go with their gut
i wonder this might sound a bit meta
but
again i'm talking from personal
experience here which is probably not
very scientific
but what i'm pitching here is that
can can we rationally accept that
there's a sort of advantage of having
gone along with your gut instinct that
might make the feeling of
might change how it would feel
afterwards so in other words to to get
something wrong that at least you went
with your gut feels better than to get
something wrong when you tried to
overthink it and went against your gut
yes so there's certainly uh the
phenomenon of making decisions
proactively that you won't regret
um
the that uh
the pain of regret can be
so aversive that you take the safe
course of action so that nothing can
happen that that would make you feel uh
you know like a
total idiot after the fact um
so certain precautions that we take so
it's a one example of what tversky and
kahneman call loss aversion
that we
a purely rational decision maker would
weigh the costs and benefits
and
choose the option that has the highest
expected utility namely the
costs and benefits weighted by their
probabilities okay so you know what what
could happen with what are the chances
that it could happen multiply the chance
by how good or how good or bad it is
positive or negative add them all up
take the option that has the uh the
highest value uh kind of interesting
showed that people don't exactly follow
that because they give much more weight
to the downside than the upside
they'll uh
you know if there's a a uh
a bet that they would
um
uh
lose a certain amount or gain a certain
amount even if on average every time
they play
they would increase their earnings the
pain of losing
uh
so much offsets the pleasure of winning
that people will often avoid gambles
that would pay off and it might be
so there's some of that that that i
think is is relevant to your scenario
there may also be cases where your
affective emotional reaction
is itself a criterion
such as if uh
if there's a particular job that takes
place in some you know depressing
windowless fetid place
and you have an emotional reaction to
that well how happy you are on the job
is going to depend a lot on your
emotional reaction day-to-day and your
emotional reaction to the thought of
taking it might be a good predictor of
your emotional reaction when you're
actually doing it and there's nothing
irrational about factoring in your own
emotions right uh in fact quite the
contrary
rationality always
is in pursuit of some
uh some goal and and that goal depends
on on
what you want and how you feel
[Music]
[Music]
you